dent and how they play against that  backcourt secondly  rebounding the basketball you got to be  able to box the bags from  utah off the glass and so you can get  out and run  two teams swap turnovers to begin the  game and there's the stifle tower seven  foot one rudy gobert the man in the  middle  for utah and if this isn't coveted  basketball you gotta go into the stands  and get your own ball  yeah i was thinking about that one no  you took the words right out of my mouth  don't touch it fans don't touch the ball  here comes mike conley the veteran  in his fourteenth big guys under the  basket so here's the story of that  basketball at the games  start they said no no no you go back sir  easy buddy we'll take care of this they  don't want anybody coming out of the  stands touching the basketball  i mean you got to know better